hey guys Pete here it's time for the
weekly spoiler report spoiler report
means spoiler so if you don't want to
learn about what's going on on the
season 7 filming set or where the cast
is then you don't want to watch this
video instead you could check out my
Arthur Dayne video I put out yesterday
and you can learn all about my book
giveaway in that one everyone else make
sure you stick around to the end so that
you can find out about the book giveaway
and let's jump right into this so the
first bit of news actually came from
Belfast and we've been talking about the
wolf hill quarry scene for a while now I
guess for about a month huh we know that
the Hound hörmann Davos a bunch of
whites and John Snow are all up there
and we found out that Alan Taylor is
going to be directing this episode since
we know which episode he was going to
direct episode 6 we know that this is
this actual sequence is going to be that
crazy penultimate episode that we've
grown used to over the years a while
back we talked about what's probably
gonna happen in the season finale so
this makes sense this big battle in the
north which we can pretty much assume is
going to be against the night's king and
a big old gang of whites is going to be
the big you know climactic whatever you
want to call it the episode that you
know kind of defines the end of the
season the setup there's been pretty
close so we haven't seen much we've seen
we saw when they were getting the frozen
lake ready and we've seen a couple
pictures of the actors around town and
just that one picture last week of Jon
Snow in costume filming so it's not like
Spain but don't worry we're gonna get to
Spain here in a second as things were
getting set up in cáceres the Twitter
account of Lena Headey posted a few
pictures of her and the mountain
traveling to Croatia so we had talked
last week about how they were probably
gonna shoot a little bit of stuff in
Croatia this season again even though it
was originally not planned and then
Cersei or the actress that plays Cersei
posted some photos of her
the mountain traveling there together at
the same time we got a bunch of photos
of them setting up in casseras so both
of these areas were active at the same
time since both of these places were
active at the same time I'm going to
jump around in time a little bit before
I talk about Spain I'm gonna talk about
Croatia because they got some really
cool photos of Cersei and Jaime shooting
there the mountain was also on hand and
we got to see a couple images of Circe's
new King's Guard uniforms you can see
they're wearing black now and the exec
Nia on their chest plate is similar to
the crown that she wears at the end of
season six when she takes the throne so
that's an interesting look and a big
change for what you knowwe seen the
Kingsguard looked like before and we
also got another director sighting this
time we see Jeremy Padilla
who's shooting the premiere and the
finale talking with Lena Headey about
the scene or whatever so I think this
stuff is probably in the premiere it
could be either but I think it's
probably in the premiere because we know
that in the finale there's a lot of
scenes going on around the dragon pit
with some of these same characters you
know what I mean so this kind of seems
like it has a different feel than the
finale so I'm gonna guess that this is
probably something that we see right at
the beginning of the season to catch up
on what's going on with the Lannisters
they're in King's Landing they did shoot
in Croatia for a couple more days but
none of the actors were involved so it
looked like they were filming scenes
that were just basically backdrops and
we did get to see the first bit of snow
in King's Landing and one of the shots
so it looks like maybe they were
shooting some stuff that would be you
know in-between or filler type scenes
Jeremy methd aremy Podesta was still
there so not really sure I mean the snow
falling makes it seems like it's the
finale but does that mean that that
happens at the same time as when they're
on the wall you know the where we saw
the cockers on the walls there it's
really no way to tell and obviously we
didn't see any snow and their scene so
was it have to wait and see different
stars started to show up in Spain as
well we saw Illyria sand
and her daughter tyene sand show up and
then that kind of got the wheels turning
on what we were talking about a long
time ago your on coming to the city and
pledging his fleet to Cersei so I'm not
gonna go over that whole thing again
there's a whole video about it it's in
the it's in the spoilers playlist it's
called season 7 production spoilers the
Greyjoy's but a couple days later hoy
dumped a bunch of photos from Caesarea
that shows that this is what's going to
happen we see Euron come through town we
see that he has the sand snakes in tow
and then we see that he also is leading
his niece Yara so this pretty much is
playing out like we thought except for
we thought maybe that one of the
Greyjoy's might have died in that battle
and we saw Theon pop up later so now we
know Yara you know didn't die during the
battle but she's not in a very good spot
as she's being brought through town in
front of the Queen with her uncle that's
basically you know the biggest
psychopath in Westeros pretty much like
I said in my ear on video
you know the showed Euron's really
watered down compared to what we know
about your on in the books but even if
they do a little bit about like Euron's
craziness then this will be an exciting
twist with him on the same side as
Cersei on top of these photos being
awesome we also got a shot of Mark Malad
who is slated to direct episodes 2 & 3
now watch it on the wall says that this
is episode 3 that's their guess and I
think that makes the most sense so this
is really kind of exciting when you
think about the sequence what I said
when we made that sea battle prediction
a few months ago was is that I hope that
the season actually opened with the
battle at sea now that would look to be
the case if this is episode 3 because
you know we have we still have Danny
getting to Dragonstone at that same time
and all that stuff going on so you can
see how fast everything's going to move
you know there's going to be a battle at
sea between half of Danny's forces the
ones led by the Greyjoy's you're on
obviously wins and then
his spoils to the Queen to forge their
alliance at the same time we'll have
Danny over and Dragonstone getting
together with John Snow from what we
heard earlier we'll be seeing John and
his fan to people that we talked about
in a you know a few videos back headed
an up north to try to capture a white so
you know the pace is gonna be pretty
astounding because we got this giant
ambush thing that's gonna fit in between
all that stuff so pretty exciting stuff
after the big Iran stuff we got a photo
that showed that John Bradley who plays
Samwell had shown up in Caesarea so
which might sound weird but Watchers on
the wall had reported it a while back
that they would be filming both Old Town
and King's Landing so don't get confused
here it's definitely he's definitely
there for old town scenes we got a
glimpse of him while they were shooting
in the other area but then the next day
we got a bunch of photos that include
him and Gilly and it's in the other part
of town the plaza that they you know
they weren't using for the parade so we
got to see some pretty cool stuff here
we got to see them looking like they're
packing up their stuff including little
Sam and getting into a cart and leaving
Old Town which I mean it looks like
they're Lee when we can't know for sure
but it's also interesting that they're
sort of bundled up so that's probably a
good indication that they're headed
north which would be interesting since
you know Samwell would likely be headed
towards John we also got another
director sighting here and it was Matt
Jackman he's right in the middle of the
season he's doing four and five episodes
four and five so again it we have an
idea that this fits in the timeline in
the middle of the season if I remember
correctly the last time we saw him was
on the shore when Theon came to
Dragonstone so this would be happening
concurrently with that after we saw the
you know Gilly and Sam shooting we also
saw that crew was packing up and leaving
this was the last day of shooting for
casseras and where we go from here I'm
not really sure I mean Wolfe Hills
but we're not getting much info from
there and at this point most of the you
know filming locations are done like the
most of the outdoor scenes have been
shot so we're gonna have to play it by
ear going forward and obviously when
they're up at Titanic studios in Belfast
we won't get any photos from inside
there so that's it from the set this
week there was a little bit of a teaser
about the Game of Thrones prequel or you
know the other project HBO's CEO was in
Madrid for the opening they were
promoting HBO Spain Davos was there and
Bernard Jeffrey Wright from West world
but he basically said that the Game of
Thrones spin-off is still in the
embryonic conversation stage which is a
direct quote when he was talking to The
Hollywood Reporter so I made a video
about this a while back I mean I think
it's a done deal they're gonna do
something and I went through all the
different ideas I thought of what might
make sense but I don't think they're
really gonna promote it openly or even
give us an idea of what it's about
until we at least get to you know like
pregame for season 8 I don't think
they'd want anything to take away from
season 7 right now but that's gonna be
it for this week I hope you enjoyed the
video definitely give it a like if you
enjoyed it make sure that you if you
have any questions you leave them in the
comments if you have anything you want
to theorize about it was a pretty
exciting week it's cool to see you know
that Yara was still alive at least at
the point there was some concern about
that at least at the point whenever they
get to King's Landing photos themselves
of Euron's outfit and you know the way
his horse was dressed up was really cool
and getting to see Cersei and Jaime
together on set and having a couple
scenes with Sam and Gilly is also good
stuff to see next week I'm not sure if
there's more news I will do a bit
regular spoiler video on Saturday but I
was sort of planning on doing a
Christmas recap of all the spoiler
videos no one really goes back and
watches the old ones anymore and we've
learned so much going into it I'm not
really sure if I could
put it all in one video would be really
long but maybe I'll do that since it is
Christmas time or else I'll start up
parts like break it up into parts like
the North Dragonstone King's Landing and
do a few videos to recap all the stuff
that we've seen so far the book giveaway
is still going on so make sure you
subscribe now and leave a comment to
enter I'm giving away the Illustrated
20th anniversary edition of a game of
Thrones by George RR martin once i hit
28 k subscribers we're almost at 25 now
so we're two-thirds of the way there and
to win all you got to do is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video or any of the other ones where i
mention this particular giveaway thanks
for watching i'll talk to you soon